Thank you. Um, my name is Nikki Amab.
I've been doing uh infrastructure
security for the last 10 years. Uh, we
built security tools at Google, Data
Dog, and Snapchat.
Um, today I'm going to be talking about
a problem that I saw when multi- aenic
workflows started appearing in the
enterprise scene. uh we talk about some
of the research and implementation we've
done with a group of my collaborators at
tenure and a new primitive we've
implemented to solve the problem.
Uh over the last 5 10 years in the
industry we've been talking about
workload identity. The whole point of
local identity was that if you pull a
pod on a nod, you have to make sure that
it's the authorization it's using is
actually matching the intent of who
deployed that pod. The point was that
the lifetime of a pod doesn't always
match with the lifetime of the node. The
problem is again the workload was a
deterministic
service. We knew what was going to do
and there was no surprises. With a
genenic workflows, we have these pieces
of software that can reason at runtime.
They can spawn other sub aents and when
you're deploying them, you have no idea
what's going to happen at runtime. We
think this is one of the fundamental
reason why we end up with confused the
problem when we deploying a genic
workflows on the infrastructure that
we've been building for the last couple
of decades.
Now the reason this happens is because
we're giving them um ambient authority
when their architectural fundamentals
are built on derived authority. The
concept of dergation I'm going to give
an example of our valet experience. When
you go to a valet there's two ways to go
about it. Either you check the badge of
the valet and you're like okay they work
at this company. I'm going to give them
the key of my car. Except this key can
allow them to drive the car around the
city. They can open the trunk of the
key. They can open the uh glove box.
Anything that you do with your car. But
none of these has anything to do with
the actual valet service you're looking
for. What if there was another option of
a valet key? This key is geoenced. They
can't drive for more than 2 kilometers
from where you are. it is the speed is
capped at 40 kilometers or miles per
hour. Um the key can only
uh allow them to drive the car but they
won't be able to open the glove box or
the trunk or any other auxiliary uh
features you have in your car. We
believe this is how proper delegation
should happen for agents. You should
give an agent the authority that is um
specific to the task you want them to do
in the moment.
uh the
what we call the containment problem is
that when you use the valet key, you
don't have to trust the valet who is
helping you. You don't you don't have to
check you know it's great if they did
the background check if it's great if
it's a nice guy. It's great if you you
have a good feeling about them but you
don't have to trust them. The delegation
key is the enforcement. Now the valet
can have ideas, the valet can have uh
suggestions from their friends but they
won't be able to go beyond the authority
you gave them with the key. We want to
bring that to aic workflows. We believe
that uh while uh we can have a way to
improve the thought process of the valid
the thought process of the model we for
having proper security we need
deterministic controls that can actually
constrain what the agent can do when we
use uh a filter or a model gradually
what we what we're trying to do is look
at the model output uh use probabilistic
approach to suggest really to the model
what can and what cannot do. You're
looking at the content layer. But the
problem here is that you don't have you
you you basically working with
confidence levels. You can't really
audit and know why it made the decision
that it made. And when you get into
enterprise when we start having a
genenic workflows touch infra touch pi
data touch money we're going to need
deterministic predictable and auditable
authorization that that's where we think
the uh the end game of authorization of
agents should be on the execution layer
when the agents actually meets the real
world.
If you go in many enterprise uh
infrastructure today, you will see that
yes, we have workload identity. Great.
Uh we deciding what agent can do based
on the identity it was given at the
deploy time. We have policy engine which
are very valuable. They can define what
the agent can do and what the agent
can't do. We have model output filters
which can um filter and see if the
output of the model is safe or not. We
have sandboxes which uh have uh a global
limitation of the possibilities that of
what can happen at the execution time.
However, we don't really have a
primitive that addresses the fundamental
architecture of multi- aents which is
delegation. when when a given task goes
to agent A and agent A delegates to
agent B at the execution time we don't
really have a primitive that can express
the delegation chain the authority that
came with the task all the primitives we
have are relying on the identity of the
workload in the moment or the output of
the model without the context of the
flow of the task up to the execution
point we missing that deterministic
delegation aware
uh authorization that can actually
encode all these properties. The idea of
capabilities which we are uh basing our
primitive on is not new. It's been
around for around more than 60 years. In
the 60s Dennis and Vanhan uh brought the
idea uh as one of the ways really to
address the problem of confused deputy
there's been a lot of research and
application different areas. of 2014 uh
Google released macaroons which was a
which uh introduced now um applying uh
science applying these tokens with
caveats that that's where now the idea
of actually attenuating what these uh
tokens can do started appearing in um in
in late 2010s and early 2020s you can
and the biscuits uh added the idea of
cryptographic tokens uh following the uh
the capabilities model. Uh very recently
last year in March uh deep mind team
released a paper um famously known as
the chem paper. Uh I believe the name
was defeating prompt injection by
design. It was the first time they
suggested that capability authority
capability based authorization is the
model that can help address the problem
of prompt injection. Today they were
using a two agent model or they call
they call PQ model where you have a
privilege agent and the actual worker
and they were mostly looking at the data
flow during the agenic workflow. very
recently u February 12th they released
another paper they called it intelligent
AI design reiterating the same idea that
the proper framework to breed
authorization for multi-agenic
workflows is to use capability systems.
So that's what we've been building at
tenure uh applying capability uh
principles uh building upon the proven
primitive and now applying them to the
reality of aenic workflows. Now the
primitive what we call the tenual
warrant has six properties. One, it is
signed by the issuer. Uh that's where
the cryptography piece comes in. It's
signed by the issuer. It is sculpted to
the the task at hand explicitly. If a
task is not encoded in the warrant, the
agent is not going to be able to do it.
It is ephemeral. Uh short TTLs are part
of the design. It's customizable but we
believe it should not really give the
agent authority beyond the temporal
scope of the task that it's doing. It is
hold the the proof of possession is a
fundamental principle of this primitive
unlike some of the previous uh designs
that were mostly relying on or of
tokens. Uh it is verifiable offline. You
don't have to rely on a central server
to call to check if the the artifact is
valid or not to to do any of this
verification. It can all happen by any
implementation of the of the verifier
offline anywhere in the world. It is
delegation aware. It encodes the whole
delegation chain from the original
mentor of the original warrant to every
agent in between. As you can see, this
is an example of a more representation
of of the um of the warrant primitive.
But an example I like to give is that of
a corporate debit card. If you have an
intern that's going on a business trip,
you don't give them the corporate MX
with all the spending limits. You give
them a task specific card with limited
number of vendors that can be used for
transportation and uh and dining. Maybe
that that will expire at the end of the
week, at the end of the trip and uh it
is bound to them. They can't give it to
nobody else. They can't spend more than
a set limit and uh when they going to
pay, they don't have to call you to
validate the warrant that you gave them.
So this is the same model that we
applying here and uh making sure that
across the protocol we make sure that
the warrant has these six properties.
How does that fit into the delegation uh
workflow? The idea here is that the top
warrant can mint the agent
can meet a warrant with broad access
depending on what the task needs. But uh
it can set it can say create and
delegate to multiple sub aents with
scoped subw warrants. The idea here the
mathematical principle is that the
warrant of the child agent can never
exceed the scope of the parent agent. So
we it's the principle commonly known as
monotonic attenuation. So as you
delegate further downstream in your
multi- agent workflow the capabilities
of the agent can only shrink and uh we
also making sure that we have that
cryptographic provenence of the
delegation chain both at which are
checked at the uh execution at the
verification phase but also as a
byproduct of this design we ended up
having now cryptographic audit logs
tempor
that that that can prove who approved
the what, who initiated the task, who
delegated to what agent and you don't
have to trust anybody in between because
you have uh the cryptographic receipts
of the action that took place and why it
was authorized. Uh the idea here again
is that at least you are sure that the
blast radius is frozen when you're
starting your task. You bounding what
your flow can never do. your open claw,
you can be sure that it can only do what
you intended from the top warrant. No
matter how many agents it it spawns
downstream, they can never have more
authority than what you gave the um the
top parent agent. And uh there is more
to this than some of the uh features
we've been putting in place of approval
processes. Uh but I I just want to go
straight to the uh to demo and uh and
show you how this looks in practice.
So what I'm going to show you in this
demo is a scenario. Say you are um you
are a detection and response team. What
you're doing here is you are you there
is an incident and you have an agenic
workflow that can help you triage and
investigate the incident. You have two
agents. One is a triage agent. Another
one I'll show you here. One is a triage
agent, another one is an investigation
agent. So you mint a broad warrant on
the top. You give it to the triage agent
and depending on what it need from the
investigation agent, it will um it will
mint the warrant for the task. So you
have uh you have your setup here. I'm
using real agents actually I'm using
lang graph uh here as an an example and
in this scenario here we are
investigating the author service. Um the
integration we're using with langraph is
so we built the core in rust which is
open source by the way and uh we we we
added python bindings to make it easier
to integrate with different frameworks.
In this case with lang graph it's just
one line to replace the tool node with
10 tool node and at the execution it
will make sure it checks the warrant.
Now the example here we're starting with
is how the dgation goes from the sock
lead who means a warrant to the triage
agent who who means now another warrant
to the investigation. When the sock lead
gives a warrant to the triage agent it
drops the capability to isolate the
host. just gives it okay you can send
HTTP you can read config you can read
logs to this particular service and then
we have this is an example of how
warrant looks like we have a playground
online teno.ai AI you can see like
playground to actually put in a uh a
warrant to to decode it and see what it
is supposed to do. Um but here I just
want to show one case where the happy
path it goes from the so to the triage
agent to the investigation agent. It
reads the logs all the uh actions it
tries to do are encoded in the wallet.
Everybody's happy and this is the
intended purpose. Now imagine a
situation where in the logs that it is
reading there is a prompt injection that
suggests to the investigation agent like
hey how you know the problem you're
investigating is related to a um a
problem in the vault there is a
credential problem maybe you can look
into this uh particular path that has
token information that is how typical
prompt injection happens but since the
triage agent stripped down the scope of
the investigation agent to just reading
ing the file path of the off service it
will it will never be able it will be
denied by tenure at execution time to be
able to actually read the uh vault file
path since it's not in the um in the
wallet another case you have here is uh
is when the um the the investigation
agent is tricked into sending some of
the information to evil attacker.com
again as you remember when we were
delegating from the triage to the
investigation agent, we stripped down
send HTTP capabilities. The the um the
uh investigation agent in this
particular moment doesn't have a
warrant. The task it's been given, the
warrant is been given doesn't allow it
to be able to actually send HTTP. So,
it's going to be denied
deterministically and uh and with
cryptographic proof by the tenual
verifier. Now if it for example if the u
the triage agents want to send sim logs
to the sim yeah yeah it has the send
http capability and this happens to be
an internal URL that that is in the
warrant great there is there's a happy
path there but uh again even if it has
this capability if it tries to the path
that wasn't specified in the warrant
it's going to fail and be denied by um
by tenure verifier the Last case I want
to show is the the property I mentioned
of being holder bound proof of
possession. If uh we don't consider a
warrant to be a a a secret credential.
So if you have a warrant and it's stolen
and you don't have the the private key
of the holder, it's going to be denied.
That is the last case we have here. And
with all these cases, we have audit
trays. We have what we call a
cryptographic receipt that you can send
to the control plane and have them uh be
uh cryptographically verifiable audit
logs of all the events that are
happening in infrastructure. This is
just an example of how these uh receipts
looks like but the idea here you can all
play in different environments. This is
the core is open source and uh we talk
more now about some of the lessons we've
learned around the way. The first
question that comes here is like how
does this fit into my infrastructure? We
have four deployment models we've been
looking at. One is in process like the
example I gave with lang graph. Uh some
different um
frameworks have middleware hooks that we
we've been plugging in. So far we have
nine framework support including crew AI
including A2A uh we have um temporal and
many other frameworks. Another
deployment mode is side the car we have
you can if you have like a mesh service
for example you can have tenure as one
of the extension of your envoy so that
before you hit actual APIs tenure can
actually verify your the warrant of the
agent running on that particular pod. We
have the gateway approach. If you
already have an infrastructure of
agents, all you have to do is send 10
warrants in headers. They are no secret.
They can go in HTTP headers. And when
you actually uh calling remote APIs, the
gateway is going to be stopping um is
going to be stopping the
um
the execution if they are not in the
warrant. The idea here is to look at all
deployment modes that real companies are
actually uh using and most companies are
now afraid to go to production because
they don't have these primitives to help
them really express their policies in
the infrastructure architecture of
multi- aent. Another one we have is MCP
proxy either as on the client side or on
the server side or both for the fencing
depth. Again the idea here is that
before it hits your proxy tool. This is
actually one of the easiest
implementation we have because proxy uh
MCP has a structured uh tool and
argument definition. So it's easier for
us to express that when one thing I want
to be clear about is that tenure is not
trying to solve prompt injection. We're
trying to constrain the agent at
execution time even if it is prompt
injected.
We we we are not trying to be like
there's not going to be prompt
injection. I'm not trying to say there's
no going to be house nation but we are
making sure that the authorization is
frozen even if your agent is prompt
injected. We've been uh one of the
challenges we run into is that there
isn't really a a public benchmark for
multi-agentic workflows that can test
authorization in multiple hubs. We've
built a custom one. Uh the cryptography
side we had uh 53 test with more than
5,000 fuzzing scenarios. We basically
trying to make a NLM come up with
adversarial situations that can actually
trick Tenu into allowing it to to to do
unauthorized actions. And we've seen
that with tenure versus uh tenure
deployment when you have cleared the
definition of scope. we moved the attack
surface to from from 90% to 0% when you
have tenure on the performance side like
I mentioned earlier we've been you we we
use uh rasco for actual authorization
and cryptography verification and we
make sure uh that uh everything every
authorization action happens in the core
a big lesson we learned is not is that
the map is not the territory when you
run into the real world since CVS in
this space if you only stay in the
constraint logic, you're going to find
issues of um path traversals. You're
going to find issues with encoding your
URLs. So, we've been moving a step
further to look at three layers. One is
what we call the map uh where you have
your logic, your rejects, your globe
matching logic, beautiful, it's a gray.
But we learn that the all those logic
and your cryptography are not really the
botonic. We have to look at the real
world. The other layer we call it the
attenuated map where we have now
constraints that can actually understand
the target if it we have uh one that can
actually normalize paths and URLs. But
we believe that there is another area
what we call the actual map where you
have to actually be have your logic and
you run the time environment speak the
same language. That's where we've built
some tooling some open source tooling
around it on um execution guards for
file system and uh and process running.
But uh eventually to get this right
believe it's matching the warrant system
onto a sandbox that can actually uh
understand
what the warrant is trying to say. So
one of the things we are looking for
what is next we are looking for
researchers who want to collaborate on
breeding benchmarks for multi-agent
authorization. There isn't really good
benchmarks out there. We're looking for
people who are actually running a
genenical workflows in practice who want
to uh stress test this model. We're
looking for uh people who want to
explore uh further way that this
primitive can be applied in different
frameworks. If your company has a
framework, if your company is coming up
with new architecture and wants to have
capability based authorization in place,
be our friend. We can talk. And more
importantly, we want the open source
community to help validate the primitive
and uh either build with it or break it.
Thank you so much.
All right. Well done, Nikki. I love it.
Um let's do some questions from the
online crowd just real quick. Um Kayn's
asking, "Very cool talk. In practice,
how do you determine the scope of the
token issued to the child agent at
runtime? Is that scope determined
deterministically by the system or can
the LLM interpret what that scope is
needed for the task?
>> Uh that is a very good question. How you
define the scope? Uh so the idea here
again is that the policy is going to be
deterministic. That's the goal. And at
least as you start your delegation chain
from the human or from another
deterministic process, you could have a
simple web who could start from like a
certain alert. You can have the initial
uh walrant defined by a human and uh at
the runtime there are two ways you can
go about it. One first of all since you
are sure that no sub agent can ever do
more than the parent you have already
frozen the capability of the whole
workflow. Two ways you can go about one
is like having the orchestrator which is
a typical design the orchestrator at
runtime itself decide which task it
wants the sub agent to do the child
agent. Again the guarantee you have at
the top is that the whole workflow will
never go beyond the frozen scope you've
defined. Another way we have that we
didn't have time to go into is having
some of the constraints be uh added with
approval considerations where you're
like okay you can do this action and uh
this argument but only if this
particular key pair approves the uh that
action at runtime. So we have the
approval processes but we we started
with uh the uh the orchestrator deciding
at runtime what task it wants to give to
the agents and if you want more human in
the loop control we also have the
approval process. Thank you.
>> Uh great talk just a real quick question
on um you mentioning that warrants
aren't secrets
um and how you go about uh
authenticating the the agents.
>> Thank you. So the warrant itself is that
artifact that the agent shows to the
verifier. As a matter of fact, like I
mentioned earlier, you can go to our
playground. We have it here. You can
paste any warrant. This is the client
side. It's a was we built on the top of
the Rascal. And when it's present to the
uh the verifier, what the verifier does,
there are two steps. There are there's
the authorization step to actually check
the constraints versus what it's trying
to do. And then there is the
cryptographic check to confirm that it
was signed by the issuer to confirm that
it was coming from the provenence from
the root key of the chain and to confirm
that it is being sent by the the right
agent. So we have an envelope um an
envelope structure where you have the
warranty self which is not a secret but
in the envelope you have all those
signatures and the other evidence that
prove that the agent is supposed to do
what it is doing. Uh did I answer the
question?
All right, any other questions?
>> Hey, great talk Nikki. Um, so I'm
wondering how do you map these
capabilities to my domain specific
permissions? Like for example, I might
be using oath related on my applications
or AWS or any of the other things. So
how is that capability translated into
actual action uh permissions?
>> Okay. Yeah. So to talk about our
constraint language actually which is
was which was a a big discussion because
we were optimizing for expressivity
security and and uh performance. So our
constraint language has the basic
logical operations the rejects I
mentioned about and we also support CL
so that you can express uh everything
you want. Now if there are two pieces of
the question if I understand well one is
the API call uh that is typically like
any other tool call that you can do if
you're using MCP we we can map to the
tool and the argument if you're calling
a a random URL we can do the the uh the
host and the the path or the other
arguments if you're calling any IP API
we can there are two ways to go about it
either you can uh have teno what we
prefer is that teno sits on the top of
your actual authorization in the system.
So before actually you hit your IM on
GCP or IM on AWS, you check that the API
call is in the orient, we express it
just like you would do any other API
call and when it hits the authorization
system of your your cloud, it does
whatever it wants. But in most of the
cases because the workload identity is
scoped to the workload, the
infrastructure, it is way wider than
individual task that you're doing. So if
that task is not in the wallet, the ten
tenno is going to stop it in the moment.
But there's another question I think I
want to address there where like
especially when it comes to approvers
and all like you have real human
identities and uh that is more on the uh
enterprise design that we've been
working on as well where you can
actually have those approver key pair be
mapped to real human identities that u
your Google ID or your uh actor SSO can
actually be used to make those approval
without losing the cryptographic purity
of the protocol itself. Yeah,
>> thanks a lot. I really love this idea of
warrants. I've had the idea the uh
thought for the past couple months after
doing a bunch of prompter GTFO and
seeing the havoc where I was like we
need to like wrap the actions of the AI
agents into like a finite state automa.
You know, there's too many horror
stories out there of like, oh my god, it
did this, it did this, it did this. And
it seems like this is, especially the
open source section, it seems like this
is one of the first steps towards like
actually creating that boundary. I
really like it.
>> Thank you very much. Thank you.